let's bring in our panel here in Hanoi
Eric Talmadge is the pyongyang bureau
chief for The Associated Press and Jeff
Earl is the deputy US political editor
for The Daily Mail thank you gentlemen
for being here Eric your your sense
first first of all there's a rare
element that the North Koreans come out
and hold a press conference clearly they
wanted to put their point of view out
there your sense of where things are
after this summit fell apart I think the
North Korean side was clearly surprised
by the outcome I think they're
disappointed and so they wanted to make
sure that they got their position across
they took a little bit of an issue with
president Trump's claimed that they were
claimed that they wanted all sanctions
removed although they pretty much
admitted that they were looking for
pretty much all the sanctions to be when
you're talking about the sanctions
you've got these UN sanctions the five
of the eleven it's essentially the meat
of the sanctions would be taken out if
they drop those right that's right so
the North Koreans came out with a really
big ask right from the beginning and so
it's not really surprising that that
didn't work out but I don't think we
should keep in mind that they also Kim
also vowed to maintain his moratorium on
missile launches and nuclear tests and
that's a really big deal so we don't
need to go right back into crisis mode
we can continue talks and I think the
door was left open for that so that's
that's an important outcome Jeff the
president will be on sean hannity show
tonight we have a piece of that talking
about his reaction to this deal
take a listen they wanted to de luca's
and i wanted everything and the
sanctions are there and i didn't want to
give up the sanctions unless we had a
real program and they're not ready for
that and I understand that fully I
really do I mean they spent a lot of
time building it and that doesn't mean
the world has to be happy but I wanted
them to dean ook
you know a lot of times these things are
baked in the cake that the the lower
level officials go in they do all the
grunt work and then the leaders come in
and kind of pull the rabbit out of the
Hat this time it's the two leaders
really doing the negotiating absolutely
and there's a reason for that
because that leaves you less likely to
be in a situation where you fly eight
thousand miles and you don't have
anything physical to show for it now
this is a unique situation and Kim
jong-un does not the leader of every
country in the world but I think
President Trump you know invested a lot
in his personal diplomacy and so far we
don't have anything to show for it but
the walk away does that give him more
street cred in the region or back home
well I think people who and the North
Koreans watch President Trump very
closely and I think people who know him
know that this is a classic negotiating
tactic for him so if he's if he's
unwilling to take their initial ask and
walk away and demand more I mean I think
they know but that's a little bit about
what's going on and I think also trumpet
mr. Pompeo I also know that the North
Koreans are trying to make a bid here do
you think the North Koreans will come
back and say let's talk again definitely
I don't think this is over I think this
is like Mickey was saying this is a kind
of a gambit on both sides and the North
Koreans like to come out hard in
negotiations like this so it's not
really that surprising I am a bit
surprised that both sides were more
aware of what their positions were but
this is going to continue I think and I
just want to ask you about reporting in
Pyongyang how difficult is that
I mean they're obviously watching you
but you're filing from Pyongyang I mean
that's got to be challenging it is a
very challenging job I mean we have
surprising ability to get around and see
things access has been very hard it's
I'm the only American journalist who's
regularly in Pyongyang and it's very
difficult being an American in Pyongyang
for sure that's interesting I want to
talk about the politics very quickly
Jeff here is former Vice President Biden
talking today about the fallout from all
of this
dictators you cannot think of anyone but
throwing their arms around or chosen the
word of the dictators and the folks over
even our own intelligence communities
standing before the world and taking the
word of the glamour food over the entire
intelligence community a national
reputation to be tarnished we don't know
if Joe Biden is gonna run for president
or not but he was pretty critical of
coddling dictators but most Democrats
came out and said you know was good that
the president walked away from this deal
I think it's right I mean there's a lot
of concern among some Trump critics that
he was gonna put a lot of sanctions on
the table put a formal end of the war on
the table and not get anything really
concrete in return particularly given
that North Korea has material and nukes
all over the place so I think there's a
lot of relief on the part of critics
that he didn't set us on a road that
would have given up a lot of leverage
and left it in a worse negotiation
negotiating position a little bit later
we'll see what comes next gentlemen we
appreciate your time this morning